[Music]
hello everyone hello and welcome to
today's webinar enhancing
risk stratification in early colon
cancer
with tnmi immune staging
focus on stage two t4
and zero patients i'm christy jewell of
labbert
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar
seminars presented by lab roots
and brought to you by heliodx to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
javiodx.com
now let's get started i do remind
everyone that today's event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
at the end of the presentation also
please notice you can share today's
webinar on your personal social media
just click on the social sharing tab to
let your friends and colleagues know
about today's live event now if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or you can use that ask a question box
to let us know you're experiencing a
problem
today's presentation is educational and
thus offers
continuing education credits just click
on that continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window and follow the
process
to obtain your credits i would now like
to introduce
today's presenters dr graham pogue
and dr jerome gallon dr pogue is the
medical science director
for halliodx and dr gallon is the
director in firm
cordelia research center in paris france
for complete biographies on our speakers
please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr pogue
dr gallon you may now begin your
presentations
thank you very much and thank you all
for joining us
this morning this afternoon this evening
wherever you across the world thank you
very much we are excited to
have you uh with us to talk a little bit
about
a a technology that's useful
in colon cancer and many cancers to come
here so
i am graham pogue obviously with heliodx
uh the immuno-oncology diagnostic
company
we provide oncologists and
biopharmaceutical companies across the
world
with first-in-class immune-based
diagnostic tests
ivd uh development as well as clinical
grade biomarkers
um that that are available across the
world
so i will move on to the the
uh clinical portion of this presentation
and we'll talk about what are some of
the challenges in in treating colon
cancer patients
as many of you know the the tnm
classification system
is really the gold standard for risk
assessment
of early stage colon cancers if you look
on the left
the the tnm helps to understand what is
the risk of recurrence for
for colon cancer patients but it's a bit
of an imperfect system
because if you look across the
continuum of clinical risk in terms of
staging
it's not exactly linear such that some
stage 3 patients
have a better survival profile than some
stage 2 patients and vice versa
now all of these patients are treated
with
or are undergo
surgery and then the choices depend on
the clinical stage
in terms of chemotherapy decision-making
uh types of decisions and because the
risk-based estimates are are often
not personalized for the individual
patient they're based off the population
data
many of these patients end up being over
treated
particularly when it comes to the
adjuvant chemotherapy decision and some
end up being under-treated where the
risk is thought to be low but it
actually is
is much higher
so looking specifically at stage 2
patients
amongst all of the complex
clinical pathologic uh scenarios that
are that are observed
um you know what what eventually comes
out in the in
as seen in these these study presented
and
are published in 2015 is that really the
choice to treat or not uh
stage two patients with adjuvant
chemotherapy is
highly heterogeneous depending on which
country which region which hospital
uh the the patient seeks care uh you
know ranging from
from uh for all others across all stage
two patients
seven point one percent of patients in
the netherlands get treated
uh whereas in almost 30 percent of
patients that are stage two in the us
get treated
and there's clearly not some biological
difference
amongst tumors in the us and across
different places in europe it's really
comes down to
the risk assessment and the perception
of risk for these patients
and then moving to stage three we think
about this is a scenario when almost all
patients
are treated with adjuvant chemotherapy
um
you know so if you get a hundred percent
of these patients being treated
uh up to half experience uh significant
adverse events in terms of neurotoxicity
myelosuppression uh and a number of
other
um you know types of risk to these
patients
now we we estimate that about 20
or 50 of these patients are cured with
surgery alone
and and don't need the adjuvant
chemotherapy in this setting
twenty percent of those patients uh are
end up being
cured with chemotherapy and then the
the remaining fraction about thirty
percent despite being treated with
surgery and adjuvant chemotherapy these
patients relapse
regardless so there's an intrinsic
insensitivity to
adjuvant chemotherapy for this patient
so when you think about these two
paradigms
it's it can be challenging to determine
what to do for
for these patients so the immune score
was developed
to to provide a a more individualized
assessment for these patients and um you
know the the research dates back
many years jerome gallon who is on the
uh uh the call here and
uh we're excited to have him present
today uh it was one of the inventors and
received an award for in 2019
uh um honoring his
uh his creativity and its contribution
on technological process and economic
growth
uh to improve patients lives uh this
this was first described uh you know in
the early 2000s so many years of
research have still gone on
in that interim period uh the clinical
development and validation
uh studies include over six thousand
patients uh
the the seven publications is way out of
date
uh actually by now and the the clinical
assay is now available in more than 25
countries
uh just this year actually uh the world
health organization
in their blue book um classification
criteria the essential and diagnostic
desirable diagnostic
mentions the immune response as being an
important part of the risk assessment
process and and this is really a
testament to
the the work jerome and others have have
put forward
so the the immunoscope was was developed
with this idea in mind to help early
stage colon cancer patients
in terms of better predicting an
individualized risk
of recurrence uh for
early stage colon cancer and how is this
done
uh the uh the immune system actually is
directly measured and an
immunohistochemical based analysis of
cd3 and cd8 positive t cells
and that as it is measured spatially in
terms of being in the core
of the tumor as compared to uh
being detected in the invasive margin
it's an
automated digital pathology based
assessment
ensuring reproducibility and accuracy
and it is clinically validated in
many colon cancer patients so
when we think about you know where does
this fit in with all of the other
factors
it is a multi-parametric patch
multi-parametric complex decision
whether or not to to treat these
patients
t m staging as i mentioned is probably
the the majority
uh factor in in determining what to do
and in terms of risk assessment
although a number of other factors shown
here on the bottom of this pie chart
are are typical other factors that are
included in
the decision uh of whether or not to
treat with adjuvant chemotherapy and
what is the patient's risk of recurrence
but what's important here is that when
the immune score is included
in this complex multifactorial
risk assessment process it actually
contributes a large fraction
of the information and and the
individualized risk of recurrence for
the the individual patient
so let's move into some of the evidence
here supporting
the use of immunoscore for clinical
decision making and risk assessment
um particulates focus on stage two
first in 2018 uh is published in the
lancet
uh frank pagez uh jerome gallon and
others
published a a
a multi-uh international consensus
validation the immunoscore it was a
massive effort
led by the society for immunotherapy of
cancer group
and the statistical analysis was
independently performed at the mayo
clinic
here in minnesota and uh this this
analysis included over 2500 patients in
total
in the subset of stage two patients as
shown in this slide
1434 patients were represented
and and what was demonstrated was that
the immunoscore
could identify patients at uh at a lower
risk of recurrence
the blue line on top being the
immunoscore high patients
where they had a high degree of immune
cell infiltration
into the tumor and the invasive margin
whereas immunoscore low patients
had a much higher risk of recurrence and
their tumors were associated with a a
lower degree
of t cell infiltration
now the question is okay so if you look
at stage two
each of those patients end up getting
treated with adjuvant chemotherapy
uh um the the clinical pathologic risk
factors
that physicians uh utilize to understand
uh and individualize the decision in
terms of risk assessment
are are a number of factors such as t4
status again tnm
um the the
characteristics of the tumor like uh
perforation and vowel obstruction
uh lymphovascular invasion poor
differentiation status a number of
other factors that uh contribute varying
amounts of prognostic information
and that help guide the decision are is
my patient sitting in front of me high
enough risk of recurrence
to to potentially warrant the use of
adjuvant chemotherapy
in this setting and so when we look at
the
the the when when a patient comes in
they're obviously
uh not treated with adjuvant
chemotherapy yet and you're trying to
make the decision of what to do for them
they've had surgery and now they're
post-surgical
patients so looking at those
the risk factors that we have the
patients that don't have
low risk don't have risk factors that
would necessarily identify them
these these patients typically don't
receive adjuvant chemotherapy in the
stage 2 setting
whereas patients with those high risk
factors that i mentioned
are the ones that are considered for
adjuvant chemotherapy
but what you see here when those high
risk patients are separated
by immunoscope the dark blue line being
highly infiltrated immunoscore high
patient tumors
those patients have a nearly identical
survival profile
as patients that are low clinical risk
and would not receive adjuvant
chemotherapy and this actually turns out
to be a
a large proportion of those high risk
patients
seven out of ten patients that that have
a
amino score high classification profile
are associated with a good
clinical outcome and uh might be uh
spared the the side effects of adjuvant
chemotherapy in this setting
[Music]
i'm going to skip that slide now we're
talking uh uh
you know the in the title of this
presentation one of the
novel pieces of data that have come out
of this uh society for immunotherapy of
cancer
consensus amino program were
the subset analysis of the t4 and zero
patients
these patients uh are
are one of the the highest risk in terms
of
the the risk assessment classification
and really this is a
population with t4 uh tumor status that
that really is
is considered seriously for adjuvant
chemotherapy decisions so many of these
patients end up getting treated uh
in the subset of uh t4 and zero patients
in the city study
this was just published uh or just
presented at
asco this this year just a month
ago these untreated patients 132
patients were untreated in this analysis
despite having t4 tumor size
and the immunoscore could identify very
significantly two different survival
profiles
where patients with immunoscope high so
highly
infiltrated tumors had really uh good
outcomes complete this is this is not
what one would expect for a t4 patient
and and these this uh these outcomes are
similar
again thinking back to a couple slides
before the the patients who have
clinical pathologic
low-risk tumors so um you know we're
talking about a 12
recurrence rate at
five years compared to immunoscore low
patients
who have uh you know almost a 59
recurrence rate at five years so really
you can differentiate using the
immunoscore
uh the patients were at low risk
compared to the patients who are really
at high risk
and in this case two-thirds of patients
were identified as having this
a biological low-risk profile
and these patients might be spared
adjuvant chemotherapy
so jerome will talk a little bit more
about tnmi
in in the next part of the presentation
but i wanted to go
over how uh immunoscore is being
incorporated into clinical decisions for
these state
stage two colon cancer patients
so if you look on the left side patients
are typically
assessed via standard clinical
pathologic
factors into two groups the low risk
and the high risk tumors for those
high risk patients they're often
considered candidates for adjuvant
chemotherapy
uh however uh you know a major
large majority 70 80 percent of these
patients
actually have a a high degree of immune
cell infiltration
at the at the site of the tumor and thus
can be reclassified as
as low risk patients in which
you know they might be considered only
for surgical management which would be a
practice changing
type of scenario for for these high risk
patients
on the other side of the clinical risk
coin the low risk
patients there are those low risk
patients that do
have a high risk of biological
recurrence
as identified by the immunoscore a low
degree
of immune cell infiltration and these
patients might be
followed more closely and and considered
as
a high risk patient so thinking about
this in a biological paradigm
and the incorporation of the immune
response into clinical
decision making uh can have a real
impact
for patients and and society in general
so i'll really quickly talk about a a
case study here
uh that uh this is these are are
this is not an individual patient but uh
this is represented for the
for the types of patients that are being
considered you know so you have a
younger male patient with a high risk
t4a clonic adenocarcinoma
poorly differentiated tumor and
microsatellite stable
this would typically be a patient this
t4
that that provided there are no other
comorbidities that would prevent
the application of or the prescription
of adjuvant chemotherapy
this might be a patient that would be
considered in the case
where the tumor two-thirds of the time
and as as shown by the validation
uh of the city data showed that uh
immunoscope was high for this type of
patient
you know they have a really uh a
much better um prognosis than one would
expect
you know 12 recurrence rate over five
years
this might be a setting where a patient
would be considered uh to to not be
uh prescribed adjuvant chemotherapy
this is particularly important in the
the the background of the the epidemic
that we're all experiencing
um you know especially in the healthcare
space
where just bringing a patient into the
hospital
treating them with a you know an
immunosuppressive chemotherapy
is really something that you want to be
sure about
because the the risk of you know if they
become infected with covid uh or with uh
sars kobe 2
the the morbidity we we think
at this point is much higher in these
patients who are
undergoing adjuvant chemotherapy and
especially you know
with uh the the consideration might be
to to
uh uh stop that therapy which in this
intention is is supposed to be curative
so you want to make sure that you
actually
are treating the right patients and the
immunoscore can help to do that
as i've shown in some of the previous
slides a lot of these patients
actually are at a very low risk of
recurrence uh and and incorporating
immunoscore into the clinical decision
making for these high-risk patients
can reduce the the the application of
vaginal chemotherapy to those who really
are the highest
risk risk patients and you know thus
preventing
uh infection associated with the
hospital and
the the application of adjuvant
chemotherapy so i think this
is uh we'll skip the stage three data
for now but
you know there's been a lot of published
literature especially this last year
talking about stage three patients
uh the the use of immunoscope to help
guide therapy and some of those patients
in terms of
the duration and uh thank you very much
again for joining us i'll turn it over
to
jerome
thank you graham thank you and
i will move to the second part of the
talk
can you hear me well is other slides
okay
so if so if so
i will move to the second part the tnmi
tnm immune classification staging system
and this is based on this multi-center
international
sitc study uh analyzing the consensus
immunoscope and um the reason we
wanted to move to a tnmi tna
mun and we actually proposed together
with
uh all the pathologists and oncologists
from the consortium
in this art review article in the
journal of pathology
in uh 2014 towards the introduction
of the immunoscope into the
classification of malignant tumors
the reason is because today when a
patient
is coming at the hospital the clinicians
and nobody knows
anything about the patient about the
immunity of the patient about the immune
system of the patient
about the immune response to cancer
because all the parameters that are
measured in routine clinical practice
are all about the tumor cells the tumor
cell characteristics
of course the the extension the invasion
the tnm staging system
plus multiple ways to characterize the
tumor cells
or tumor features with anatomy pathology
lymphatic invasion perineural invasion
the greater differentiation of the tumor
etc
plus multiple molecular features of the
tumor
but there is not a single test except
the immunoscope that can be done in
routine practice
that will tell you something about your
patient
about the immunity of the patient and so
we
uh published this international
validation of the consensus immigrants
call
for the classification of colon cancer
in landsat
with all those 100 co-authors
and following that publication i
recently uh uh presented at esmo gi so a
few days ago actually
this proposal for uh including
her first immune parameter immunoscope
into the classification of colon cancer
so moving from the tnm 8th edition
to the tnmi so the study
that was done is based on this court of
2650 patients the
median age is 67 years old
with this ratio 51.5 percent male
the number of lymph nodes at all the
stages
evaluated is 18.9
lymph nodes in the stage 2 patients the
mean number of lymph node evaluated in
the study is 20.1
and you can see here the proportion of
patients
based on the tnm8 edition so t1 t2 t3
t4a and t4b
the proportion of patients as well as
the proportion
with the end stage and the proportion of
patients
according to immunoscope stratifying the
patients with the five categories of
immunoscope immunoscore zero
the lowest immunoscope is one two three
and four
four being the highest immunoscope
and basically uh if now you look at the
current
cnn 8th edition you can see that the
patients are staged
according to the tnm staging system
based on these key stage categories and
stage categories
and end-stage categories now if we look
at the evolution
of this pnm staging system
from the fifth edition that was in 1997
um this was how it was uh patients were
staged
to the tnm6 in 202 tnm7 in 209 tnm8
in 2016 and now you can see so the
evolution and the changes
in the categories of the patients and
now you can see
the changes that will occur if you now
have
the immune evaluation of the patients
this is introducing for the first time
an immune parameter into this cnn
classification
and if you do that then you will see
that in fact you have patients
that have in fact a very high risk
based on immunoscope but in these
patients were considered low risk with
the classical tumor parameters
and vice versa there are some patients
that you would consider
high risk with pathological tumor
parameters that are in fact lower risk
now if you consider
the immunity of the patient and so now
you see the changes
in terms of proportion of the patients
that are changing categories
now if you take into consideration this
immune immunity this immunoscope of the
patient
so how does it perform to have this
novel tnmi classification so now you
introduce
and on this chart now you can see
the patients that are either changing
for a better
uh class category so a better tier
so basically having a better outcome
compared to the previous classification
or have a similar
outcome so meaning they are not changing
categories
or that have the worst outcome meaning
that the immunoscope would tell you that
the patient is in fact at a higher risk
so you have all the on the x-axis the
the
the stages from the dnm eighth edition
and now you can see at each of those
stage what is the proportion
of patients that are changing to better
in pink or worse
outcome in blue you can see that some
patients
even in stage 1 are changing for better
or changing forwards
and then you can see stage 2a stage 2b
in fact all patients in stage 2b are
changing categories either for better or
for worse
category likewise in stage 2 c
3a and i plot it for 3b just for you to
see an example of the hazard ratio
you know if you put all the patients
that are changing categories for better
you can see another ratio of 0.59
with a p-value of 0.0001
so a much better outcome better than
expected
with the tnm8 the 3b
if you now add the immunoscope and
you can see the patients that are
getting worse than 3b
with another ratio of 1.7 and also
very significant b value
so you can now have a different view
of your patients if you integrate the
immunity of the patient and this is now
the comparison of the tnm8 edition
versus this tnmi classification
you can see the exam ratio compared to
the best category stage one patients
so you can see that with the tnm8
you have some discrepancies between
stages meaning that you have patients
that are in fact
a better outcome even though they have a
worse
category like for example the 3a would
have a much better
outcome than the 2c or even the 2b
um and you can see that the 3b
will also have a worse
a better outcome than patients with
stage two
so in fact the tnm8 is far from perfect
now if you move to the tnmi you know you
can see
the tnmi category from 1a
categories tnmi 1a to 3c
the constant increase
in the azure ratio you can see
the real values of the multivariate as a
ratio moving from
2.5 as a ratio to 3.34
4.5 5.7 9.5
10 and up to 12.3 as a ratio
all p-value being extremely significant
so you have a much better way to
stratify these patients
in addition now if you look at the
prognosis of those patients and this is
a
10 years 120 months 10 years
follow up on those patients
classify now with this novel tnm immune
classification you can see the outcome
of the patients depending on the tnm
immune from one
a on the top the the purple curves here
very good outcome uh this ratio rival
here
down to the 3c more importantly
now if we plot multivariate analysis
this is the relative contribution to the
risk
comparing the this novel tnmi tnm immune
classification with the current
tnm 8th edition tnm8 you can see that
the tnmi is way superior
to the tnm8 and in fact contributes to
more than 95 percent of the risk and in
the multivariate if you now
look at the significance between
all the stages from tnm8 versus all the
stages from tnmi
all the tnmi stages are significant and
none of the tm8 stages are significant
so basically
these survival curves shows a major
stratification
and a better stratification of the
patients with the tnmi and we have
similar results for dfs time to
recurrence or
overall survive
so importantly the the last point is you
when you
want to introduce a novel classification
you have to
compare it to the previous
classification so this is the
the statistical test the delta aic
to measure the improvement from one
classification to the next
and basically it shows for time to
recurrence digital survival or overall
survival
that between the tnm edition
there was a major improvement from tnm5
to tm6
that you can see on this graph but from
tnm6
to 7 and to tnm8 in fact it was no major
improvement if any
in terms of stratifying cancer patients
but now with the tnmi you can see this
major
improvement of the classification both
for time to recurrence disease for
survival
and overall survival so how does it
translate if we
take an example we were talking about
the t4 and zero patients
with the current staging system the tnm8
you have either t4a or t4b
and those patients would be classified
as
2b or 2c and would be considered high
risk
as now if you introduce the middle score
now
you have the patients that will move
from a stage to high risk
to a stage 1b 2a
or 3a meaning that the patients
would have either a much better outcome
compared to
the existing classification or worse
outcome
which was shown on the survival curves
by graham
and if you translate that now into a
clinical decision making now you have
the patients that are either
t4a stage 2b or t4b stage 2c
and if you stratify those patients with
immunoscope now
you will have in fact 66
two-thirds of those patients being
immunoscoped high
in both categories of t4a and t4b
and those patients with a high
immunoscope in fact
have a low risk of relapse in fact are
similar to low risk patients
and in fact could be spared from
adjuvant chemotherapy
and you have the low immunoscope
patients
within the t4 population that are even
worse than the regular t4 that are
really really high risk and those
patients you of course could
consider them for adjuvant chemotherapy
finally uh uh as it was mentioned by
graham um the latest edition
of the w.h.o book for the classification
of
digestive system tumors introduced
for the first time the immune response
into the book
as an essential and desirable diagnostic
criteria for colorectal cancer
in addition to the tnm grade of the
tumors
and the immune response was uh
described as being a standardized
examination of the presence of
lymphocyte at the invasive front of the
tumor using immunochemistry for ce3 and
cd8
showing that this feature as a
prognostic power and citing
our landsat immunoscope consensus
article so since now it is introduced
into the who we think that the next
uh phase will be the introduction into
the a gcc uicc tnm staging system
to move from the regular tnm to a tnmi
tnm immune classification
and with that i'd like to conclude that
there is a
clinical value that is demonstrated in
many published studies and
and ongoing studies to use in clinical
routine
to improve colon cancer patient
management can be done
today immunoscope is available
in europe in asia in the us
and everywhere and it helps refining the
current classification
uh moving to a tnm immune classification
and taking for the first time
into consideration the patient the
immunity of the patient
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your attention and we are now
moving to the q a session
thank you dr galona and thank you dr
pogue for your informative presentations
we will now start the live q a portion
of our webinar
now to our audience if you have any
questions you would like to ask please
do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for okay
let's get started let's start with our
first question here
dr graham let's ask this question to you
how can i access amino score for my
practice
hi thank you um yes so so
we get the the question a lot of you
know this
this these data look really interesting
uh
how do i integrate this into our system
we have a a network
uh in the in the us of uh account
representatives that
you know you can send us an email you
can go to our website
uh get in contact with us you see the uh
the contact for additional questions as
well as
information about ordering um you know
they're
across the world there are a number of
uh distributors
as well as some direct uh account
representatives
with the the website and the the
email here are your central point in
case
uh you you would like to activate this
in your practice
uh just send us an email uh they're
actually you can even
request a trf on our website uh to get
access to
to immunoscore for your patients
thank you doctor and dr dr glone let's
come over to you for this question
why should i include immune response in
the tnm
over other parameters
yeah thank you for this question so um
i think the the data
speaks for themselves i mean when you
want to
integrate a novel parameter
you have to make sure that this
parameter is informative
is not redundant with other parameters
and for that there are multiple
statistical tests
of course one of the main tests is the
multivariate
statistical analysis to test the
strength and the dependency of the
parameters
and in fact when you look at all the
parameters
existing parameters that are done in
routine clinical practice so
tnm uh msi testing grade of
differentiation
venusamboli lymphatic invasion um
mucinous all the all the parameters that
you can think of and you add now
immunoscope to this parameter
immunoscope on a multivariate analysis
is the strongest parameters and
is of course significant in multivariate
analysis
and in addition to that it takes over
most of the power of the other
parameters and in addition if now you
look at the relative contribution to the
risk
and you compare the risk of attributed
to each
parameter you can see that immunoscope
represent half of the risk considering
all
stages and represent
even more than half of the risk
comparing
analyzing subsets of patients in stage 2
on stage 3.
so in fact it is the strongest parameter
ever seen
and is superior to the existing tnm
staging system so this is why we think
that
now this novel view
on cancer meaning that the immunity of
the patient
is far informative and is very
informative
and now is a strong argument for
its introduction into classification
thank you dr gallonan let's help you
answer this question as well
as well why should i incorporate an is
result
in the decision making process when we
know that t4
uh sure yeah oh actually can i go back
to one of the slides for
do other the audience seeing the slides
still
yes yes because i think the slide speaks
for itself i mean uh of course t4
is a high risk factor but now
not all patients with a t4 will have the
same outcome
and in fact they are not all of them
high risk
some of them stage 2 t4 patients
will not have tumor recurrence and some
will have tumor recurrence
so how does it stratify patients with t4
now if you add immunoscope and if you
look at the immunoscope of the patients
and this is the results basically
showing
in that very precise population of t4
patients
how does it look when the patient's
immune score high
it looks very good for the patient in
fact uh
the patient have a very good outcome
for a very long time and as you can see
here
with only 12 percent of relapse on that
population and in fact the real high
risk
are not all the t4 patients but only the
t4 who have a low immunoscope
the pinkers so you see the huge
difference
depending on the immunoscope in that
very homogeneous population of patients
being called t4
so not all t4 are high risk only the t4
with a low immunoscope are of high risk
thank you thank you now dr pope let's
come over to you for this next question
next question
how can i reassure my patient about the
de-escalation
strategy strategy
yeah that's a good question good
question
can everybody go on everybody go on you
awesome uh i i think jerome
mostly just just answered that question
actually is is
it's important to go back to the data
and understand
what is the risk of recurrence
associated
with the immunoscores if we're talking
about
uh you know the the stage two patient
and they have a tumor that's associated
with
a high clinical risk but an immune score
high
you know we're talking about a a uh a 13
risk of recurrence and you know in the
in the conversation that might take
place
uh you know you also have absolutely
have to start with the data and
have your your your patient understand
what is their risk of recurrence because
that is important to them
what do they do uh you know what what do
physicians typically recommend for these
type of patients who have
about a 10 5 year risk of recurrence
for these low risk patients you know
that typically they don't get considered
for adjuvant chemotherapy so
if you can identify a biological based
risk of recurrence that puts them in a
bucket uh
that that reclassifies them as low risk
you know that's
that's very powerful for for uh
understanding you know having the
patient understand what
their tumor is is doing how it's
interacting with the immune system and
how the
immune system is restricting it from uh
from advancement
thank you dr pogue and dr galon let's
come over to you for this next question
what momentum do you have for the aj
cc staging manual editors to incorporate
the tnmi
in the next edition the knight edition
so thank you for the question so um two
to two things of
[Music]
we have generated and published
multiple articles in particular in 2020
this year
about the importance of immunoscopes
about about both
the quality and robustness of the test
first second about the
major stratification power immunoscope
has
at all the stages so all stage
one two three we have also three
publications on stage four
we have now uh two additional
uh randomized phase three clinical
trials
uh in stage three patients showing both
the prognostic value of immunoscope
and in addition the predictive value of
immunoscope in response to chemotherapy
and of course we have all the data on
early stage stage two including the t4
patients the population
including this upcoming
article about the tnmi
comparison to the tnm8 and
in addition we have uh now this
introduction
into the w.h.o book uh the double issue
classification
this immune response criteria evaluated
by immunoscope that has been introduced
for the first time
into the who book so all these
clinical utility and and and inclusion
already in some guidelines
uh gives a path for introducing
uh immunoscope and the immune response
into the tnm staging system and to the
agc
however i have to say that i don't know
anybody on those
agcc committees and
if anyone uh knows and
good support i mean we would be more
than happy to
discuss
thank you dr dalona i'm going to help
you answer this next question
we just have a little feedback let's get
you muted like an outside gymnastics
our results from any mgs tumor testing
wes or rna-seq etc included in the
scoring
or is it strictly based on t cell ihd
staining
yeah it's uh it's only based on
immunochemistry
staining with two markers
staining for overall t cells and
cytotoxic t
cells and it's based on digital
pathology
allowing to count every single
t cell on the tissue so basically
when you have a routine slide from a
pathology department
then all the t cells that are present
on that tumor on that slice are counted
and i can tell you that the mean number
of t cells counted by the software
is 88 000 t cells
so there's a huge number of t-cells uh
and a huge number of t-cells that are
counted and it's uh purely based
on uh visual uh
and and immunochemistry based
quantification of immune cell
infiltration within tissue
taking into consideration also the
spatial information meaning the
tumor and the invasive margin of the
tumor and there's no
ngs testing required or anything like
this
thank you and i'm actually going to have
you answer one more question here
are there clinical pathological
characteristics
such as msi status that overlap
with immunoscore high condition and
is there any value in traditional stage
2 risk
factors
so um yeah so we published uh
several articles uh including one uh
in 2016 in immunity in which we
deeply analyze the relationship between
the msi status
and the middle school
so basically what we found and others
are found
and we found that in several courts and
several publications now is that
more frequently msi patients would have
a high immunoscope
however there could be msi
high patients that have a low
immunoscope and in that case they don't
have a good outcome
and vice versa there are some mss stable
patients
that have a high immunoscope as high
as msi patients and those patients are
doing extremely well
and in fact so there's a mechanistic
relationship between the dna mismatch
repair deficiency
and the immunogenic epitopes and the t
cells
however what's most what's more
important well to define what's more
important you do a multivariate analysis
and you put in the multivariate analysis
msi and immunoscope
and what's left in all the publications
uh we
we have in the landsat in the immunity
in all courts analyzed when you have
msi and immunoscope together on the
multivariate analysis
only immunoscope remains significant and
the msi
status is no longer significant meaning
that
[Music]
the strength of immunoscope is superior
to the msi
value and meaning that there is a
dependency
between msi and minor score now
talking about uh a value in the
traditional stage two risk factors
uh well this is uh seen on on that slide
that is currently
here on the on the screen these are
the stage two patients with the
traditional uh uh risk factors for stage
two
for these high risk uh uh factors
uh so venusamboli lymphatic invasion
being a default tumor etc and in fact
what you see here is that again only
the low immunoscope patients have
a high risk among those patients and
those who have a high immunoscope
are in fact similar to low risk patients
the two blue curves the dotted line
are the lowest patients and the plain
blue line
are the high-risk patients based on
pathological parameters
but they have a high middle score a good
immunity and you see that
these two groups of patients are very
similar and in fact the real high risk
are only the ones the pink ones that
have a low immunoscope
i think that
okay and thank you another question
is there any correlation between
immunoscores
and circulating biomarkers such as ct
dna
and dr galone you can answer this one as
well
so we don't have yet a formal analysis
to measure the correlation between
immunoscope and circulating
ct dna so what i can say is that
of course immunoscope is
among all the parameters that we
mentioned including
t stage including end stage is stronger
in terms of stratifying patients at all
those biomarkers
we will have to see in in the randomized
trials in which ct dna has been
performed how it correlates
it could be very complementary in fact
to
have both information the
immunoscope at diagnosis which really
tells you
is your patient's high risk or low risk
and then to have
as an additional analysis the ct dna
perform as a follow-up
analysis to see whether the patient
is relapsing and and so these two tests
could be very very complementary
for that reason
thank you doctor and we've had and we've
had so many excellent questions coming
in but i'm sorry to say we have run out
of time but i do want
our audience to know that those
questions that were submitted today that
we were unable to answer and
additionally those questions that
are submitted during the on-demand
period they will be answered by our
speakers via the email address that you
provided at your time of registration
now i do want to give dr pogue and dr
colon an opportunity for any final
comments for our audience
thank you very much for joining us
uh it was it was really it was really
station thank you for the questions and
everyone stay safe
yeah thank you all for being here and
for listening we will uh surely answer
all of your questions and uh thank you
for your attention
dr pope dr colon thank you so much for
your time today and your important
research
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor talio dx for underwriting
today's educational webcast today's
webcast can be viewed on demand
and labyrinth will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
we hope to see you again soon have a
great day
you